t 4
みなさんこんにちは
ありがとうございますおにーず最後のスピーカーになりました
北海道の情報大学3年の雪山東水戸を申します
突然ですがみなさんは小さい時から今までずーっとずーっとすぎている守備あたりかっ
てありますか
が私まあ物心ついた時からずっと癒すとか過ぎで
イラストばっかり書いてました今日私がお話しするのは
やる人が世界をつないべくお話です
私は小学生の時外で遊ぶのが大好きな子供でした
みんなでちょっとで敵が兵をしたりですとか
秘密基地を作ったりですとかでもやっぱり一番大好きがあったのは絵を描くことです
これは私が症悪性と聞い3年生か4年生前田に1年間だけで書いた涼子ばの
喉です
全部で801本の4コママンガがこの中にハグいます
その時の私の将来の夢は4コマ真ん中になることでした
というのも私が小学生の時に知っていた
え思えを書くお仕事というのが4コマかしか知らなかったんですね
でも称して私は45番マーカーを変えて友だちに見せて
数をもらえたり面白いって言ってもらえるのがすごい
うれしバッター
そして楽しい小学校生活を送ったんですけども
中学校に上がる頃には赤の良かった友達がみんな民が遠くに引っ越して行ってしまい
ました
中学校に入って私は人見知りで自分から誰かに声をかけることもできずにずっと一人で
今日一の隅にずっと座って本を読んでいるようなそんな生徒でした
そうやって中学校3年間を過ごしていて3年の時にはもう学校に行きたくなくなって
しまいました
だんだん休み月になって
高校に進むことも考えたくなくて母親にも高校に行きたくない
入ってたんですけれども母親からは
途中で止めてもいいから高校に行きなさいと言われて高校に進むことにしました
高校でもやっぱり自分から人に話しかけることも人の目を見て話すこともできずに
ずっと一人で座っていました
でもそんな私が買われた瞬間があります
1人の女の子が私と友達になってくれて
当初曲とイラスト部に入らない誘ってくれたんです
私はそれから多少曲とイラスト部に入って友達が芋づる式にたくさんできました
私も本が好きでしたしみんなも a 書くのが好きだったので趣味があってみんなと
仲良くなれました
それまでは学校が終わってすぐに
授業が終わったらバスに乗って帰る生活をしていたんですけれども
ず業が終わってからも学校のとぞ一に残ってみんなと話をしたり
品のラベル貼りをしたり餌を替えたりすごく
もしく先週の生活を送ることができました
これは私が高校生の時にイラスト部で書いたイラストです
私が3年生に上がって新入生部員を勧誘する
8時になりました
それまで図書曲は私たちが入る前までは2人次回ない
すごくそうですねマイナーな部活だったんですね
でも私たちの代になってもっとたくさん人を入れたいと思ってポスターを書いたんです
ちょうどここに書かれている絵みたいな漫画のイラストを使ってこんな楽しい所なんだ
よっていうポスターを
学校中に貼りましたするとどうでしょう
15人の新入生部員がポスターを見て図書局に入ってくれたんです
びっくりしました私はそうして自分が作ったものを見て糸がこうして図書局に入りたい
と思って来れて本当に入ってくれて
あっ自分の作ったものでこうして人が入っ
おいてくれるのはすごい素敵なことだなって思ったんです
そのうち
3年生も高場になって進路を考える時期になりました
中学校の時は何にもなりたくなかったですし
高校にも行きたくないと思っていましたが高校に入って友達と楽しく遊んで
やっぱり自分は
会に関わる仕事がしたいなと思いました
でもイラストレーター
やっぱり狭き門だと思うじゃないですか自分もやっぱり会でご飯を食べるのは難しい
だろうと考えていたので
でも
絵を描く人じゃなくても絵に関わる仕事がしたいとそう思っていました
そんな時に私
の天気になった言葉が一つあります
情報訴求力です
この言葉ご存知の方はいらっしゃいますか
この言葉は私の高校の国語の教科書に載っていた
8文章の中の造語なんですね
どういうことかと申しますと次のスライドをご覧下さい
はいこちら矢印ありますけれども皆さん
右と左どちらを見てしまいましたか
恐らく多くの人は矢印の向いている
こちら右側を見てしまうと思うんですね
右違いますね左が悪いごめんなさい
これは
8文字の情報よりも矢印んつの力の方が強いということなんですよ
でも次のスライドを見てください
西南角系でしょうか
こちらはですね請求家系です
文字では兵十一角系と書かれているんですけれども本当は角が2つも少ない請求家系な
んですね
これはこの場合は2号読み取るのが面倒くさいので
文字情報の方が先に入ってくる文字情報の方が情報訴求力を持っていると幽霊なんです
最後にもう一つだけ
8皆さんよくご存知のトイレのマークでございますが
ぞ
よくよく見ると男性が赤色
女性が青色になっています日本人はやっぱり女性は赤
男性は青のイメージがあるのでもしこんな風に色が
逆になっていたらおそらく間違ってトイレに入ってしまうことと思いますこれは人間が
いろいろで判断しているということなんですね
でも私はその話を見て
頭とか文字とか色とかで人に正しく情報が伝わるかあったはないかがかかってくるのっ
てすごい面白いなって思ったんですよ
すごいなんでその時私初めてデザインっていう言葉を知ったんですね
自分が今まで図書曲とかで見ていた本のカバーにもデザイン団さんがいるって自分が
普段見ている
標識もデザインして作っている人がいるは
すごいなーって私もそういう仕事を目指したいなと思いました
そしてここ情報大学に入学しました
情報大学に入ったのは
デザインを学びたかったのもあるんですけども
中学高校自体の暗かった自分を変えたいと思って
でもその暗かった自分を知っている人には会いたくなかったんですねなのでポロ市では
なくわざわざ電車で1時間ちょっとかかる江別市まで来てはい留学しました
ん
でも大学に入ったからはこれまでのくらいずいぶんを変えなきゃいけない
積極的にならなきゃいけないと思いましていろんなプロジェクトでしたりいろんな
コンテストに参加したり応募したりしました
こちらの写真はですね私がプロジェクトトライアルという授業で8チームの他のみんな
と一緒に最優秀賞をいただいた時の写真です
このとき私は今まで自分がやってきたイラストカーデザインになってそのデザインが
こうして認められた
あ
頑張ってよかったなと思いましたん
2年生の時にタイに行ってきました
これはですね拡大の web デザインコンテストに
8賞をいただいたんですけどもそれで
タイに行ってタイの学生と一緒にウェブサイトを作るワークショップなんですね
と言いましても
私もタイ語がわかりませんしあちらも日本語を話せないので英語でコミュニケーション
をとることになります
でも私もタイの人も英語は第二言語ですから
うまく通じない時がありますでもそんな時に私の助けになってくれたのが
イラストです
相手に伝わらなかったことも
簡単な絵に起こして伝えればそういうことなんだ
相手に伝えることができます
そこで私はイラストっていうのは言葉の壁を越えたコミュニケーションなんだと感じ
ました
そして私にとってタイは世界の広さを知るきっかけになったんですね
初めてタイの空港に降り立った時の空気や木8温度の違い
ですとかその後に目に入ってくる
報告の色の違いであったりとかこんなにたくカラスフルな特使があるんだとか
日本と違う事ばかりで海一つ越えただけなのにこんなに広い世界があるんだと思って
もっと広く世界に目を向けたいと思いました
でもやっぱり私が感じたのは自分が作るもので
人の気持ちを言い方講に動かしたい
誰かを喜ばせたい誰かを楽しませたいという思いです
そう思っていた矢先に先輩から声がかかりました
今年の3月ですねネパールのほからという町にある小学校にボランティアに行ってき
ました
アンティア
ですね私はその時自分が
ネパールで何ができるんだろう
考えたんですよ普通の学生でお金もないし
でもそうだ絵があるじゃないと思ったんですね
それで私は
日本
私たちのことを紙芝居にしたんですか用紙にクレヨンで絵を書いて
日本から来たっていう入れずとか
例えば通して支援をしようと思ったのとかそういうことを全部絵に起こしたんですね
ネパールの子どもたちには英語もまああまり通じませんでしたし
日本語も通じないですし私たちもネパール語はあまり分からなかったので絵が
it に伝えることができたんですでもそれだけじゃないんですよ
これは良いと私がネパールの子どもたちに顔にシールを貼られているところですねこれ
は
8私がネパールの子どもたちに何ができるだろうと思ったときに
伝えられることを考えたときですね絵を描くことの楽しさへを変えた時にハッピーに
なれる気持ちは伝えられると思ったんです
それでネパールの子どもたちと一緒にえおか行くことにしました
そして絵を書いて紙芝居を見せて好またちが笑顔になっているのを見てあ
よかった自分がそうして伝えたことが相手の幸せになっていうのを肌で感じることが
できてすごく嬉しかったんですね
えっ
でも私がこういったにパールのことですとか無いのことですとか今までの人生ですとか
すべて通じてを感じたのはイラストが世界をつなぐということです
私が中学高校でなかなか友達ができずに来る住んでいた時も
私と他の人をつなぐものはイラストでしたし
高じてタイに行って言葉も通じずにうまくいかない時つけてくれたのはイラストですと
ネパールでも私のそういうイラストを通して誰かの心を動かしてイラストはやっぱり
そうやって
言葉の壁を超えて
ずっと世界をつないでいけるものだと思います私もそのイラストを使ってどんどん世界
を happy にしていきたいと思いますありがとうございました